20 teachers were asked about their
favorite course seven teachers said
language three teachers said history
nine teachers said geometry one teacher
said chemistry zero teachers said
physics create a bar chart showing
everyone's favorite courses so we've got
the bar chart right over here and let's
see what we need to plot so it said zero
teachers said physics which is
surprising to me because since physics
is arguably my favorite course but let's
plot what the data has so
physics so right now it looks like it's
halfway between zero and one so i
actually have to bring the physics down
to zero
see chemistry they said let's see one
teacher said chemistry so we got to
bring chemistry up to one
now nine teachers said geometry so
geometry let's bring that up to nine
one teacher said chemistry oh i already
read that history history three teachers
said history so let's bring history up
to three
and then language seven teacher said
language so let's move this up to seven
and i think we
if i didn't make any careless mistakes
we should be done yep very good